januars hast du schon mal jemanden
angesteuert leider mache ich das sehr
oft ja und wo passiert so was letztes
mal zum beispiel ist mir entgegen ein
mann gekommen mit so ganz vielen tattoos
im gesicht und ich habe ihn regelrecht
angestarrt und der fühlte sich gar nicht
er war gar nicht glücklich damit und
schrie dann steht dahinter mir irgendwas
und ich war froh dass ich hier weg
rennen könnte das brasilianisch
beschreibt ist tatsächlich eine
beobachtung die ihr häufiger habt viele
menschen die neu in deutschland sind
wundern sich warum man in deutschland ab
und an angestarrt wird heute wollen wir
herausfinden ist das wirklich ein
typisch deutsches phänomen und wissen
die deutschen überhaupt dass sie dafür
bekannt sind dass sie menschen an
starren los geht's los geht's
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal davon gehört das
deutsche start
ja ich glaube schon ja eigentlich nicht
ist deutsche andere anstecken und so und
insgesamt in deutschland viele leute
starten
ja okay dachte dass vielleicht schon
eher
und wie würdest du es jetzt jemanden der
zum ersten in deutschland ist erklärende
erklären dieses gucken auf der straße
leuten nachgucken
ja ich würde es auf jeden fall nicht
persönlich nehmen vielleicht sind die
leute einfach nur beeindruckt oder so
weil die andere person irgendwas
ausstrahlt oder die leute mal vorteile
ich weiß es nicht kommen ganz so fahren
also anstarren ja anderen ländern mit
zuständig genauso gemacht gibt denke ich
so gerade die situation in den s bahnen
u bahnhöfen man einfach auch manchmal
nichts zu tun hat dann schaut man sich
an
hast du auch solche erleben ist dass du
dich angesprochen fühlst habe es
definitiv
grundsätzlich würde ich sagen häufig ist
schon dass das hautfarben thema
insbesondere in deutschland eine
geschichte was in meiner situation
dahingehend unangenehm ist das berliner
bin berliner geboren aufgewachsen anders
in der straße sogar und du dich halt in
dem man ist wirklich heimisch fühlt weil
dort angestarrt wird ist aber sonst
das weiß nicht wenn man halt nicht in
einem umfeld sich gerade befindet wo
irgendwie punkten erwartet wird naja das
ist einfach wenn sie damit nicht umgehen
können wie jemand ist oder jemand
reagiert oder was jemand sagt dann
machen wir das schon ja es stimmt ist es
ihnen schon passiert mir
bestimmt aber ich erinnere mich gerade
nicht also in welcher situation also für
sie ist dieses gar kein thema da kein
problem inhalte also verglichen mit
anderen ist für mich bestimmt gar kein
problem
ob das sehr oft ist weiß ich im
vergleich nicht zu anderen ländern also
ich fühle mich jetzt nicht oft
angestarrt manchmal schon versucht es
eigentlich zu vermeiden weil ich das
selbst unangenehm finde ja genau und
warum ist das unangenehm weil ich damit
glaube ich eine grenze überschreite und
jemanden ohne seine einwilligung anstatt
angestarrt ja auf jeden fall natürlich
hier erzählen sie ein bisschen darüber
was soll ich jetzt sagen also man kriegt
das mittagsmahl angestarrt wird also
egal wie man rum läuft man sich gut an
zieht oder nicht oder ob man dafür der
letzte
wenn wir dann gstaad warum machen die
leute sind sie neugierig oder merken sie
das einfach ich denke sowohl als auch
sind neugierig die muster nein so wie
sie dann aus gerade wenn man ein
bisschen extravagant rumläuft sag ich
mal wird man schon angespart hat einfach
die neugier ja kann sein doch wenn man
halt auffällt dann wird man man wird
eigentlich immer ja man wird sehr häufig
angestimmt habt ihr schon mal jemanden
angestarrt
das stimmt schon mal aber ich versuche
zu vermeiden die leute dort zu starten
aber bestimmt habe ich schon mal
jemanden an gestartet also
[Musik]
hast du schon mal jemanden angestarrt
und dann plötzlich gemerkt scheiße ich
stehe jetzt gerade den tipp nach vorne
an
ja doch doch das schon doch doch das
habe ich schon mal dabei habe ich mich
natürlich schon oft erwischt und sich um
4 regelmäßig irgendwie aber dann diese
sunstein vielleicht aufgrund von neugier
irgendwie war jemand irgendwie heraus
sticht oder irgendwie anders aussieht
oder sich anders an zieht oder irgendwie
ja wie weil es um die und welche
merkmale aufweist
die dann in dem augenblick für mich
irgendwie so interessant sind vielleicht
dann starrt man halt länger hin länger
hin und dann vielleicht doch nicht so an
starren machen doch ist das die schon
mal passiert dass du dich erwischt hast
dass du leute an straße und eine u bahn
ja und wie wird es das erklären warum
macht man sowas warum staat man leute an
weil die leute irgendwas haben so was
mich
begeistert oder abschreckt keine ahnung
man kennt die situation wenn man es weil
dann ist ein bisschen verträumt schaut
man kann ja auch mal irgendwie ein
hübsches mädel sein oder eine person
passiert also denke ich dass es kommt
schon vor und haben sie sich schon
einmal damals dabei ertappte jemanden
anzustellen und dann denken ja klar
also alles andere wäre eine selbst lüge
deswegen klar auf jeden fall ja
natürlich ich glaube es macht auch jeder
so das macht die da und ist jetzt unter
bewusst macht oder bewusst wo man trotz
schon ein bisschen
und was glauben sie warum passiert sowas
warum kommt man menschen zu lange an
oder staat leute sogar an
ja weil man sich für diese leute
interessiert und dann
pokémon zu lange das vielleicht nur
anständig ist sozusagen also das ist
durchaus teil
und wie ist es womit feldmann auf womit
wird man mehr an gestalt in deutschland
man wird angestarrt sobald man halt aus
der aus der typischen form quasi
rausfällt würde ich sagen zum beispiel
in und schwarz ist wird man angesteuert
dann ja kommt drauf an wo würde ich
sagen berlin jetzt nicht unbedingt aber
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel ein kleines
bayerisches dorf geht ganz weit weg da
wird man bestimmt angestarrt und hat
bestimmt diese erfahrungen damit ja und
wie reagiert ihr wie hast du schon
gesagt wie würdest du reagieren wenn
dich jemand in der u-bahn so anguckt es
ist unangenehm ich versucht dann die
leute also mutig genug zu sein die leute
zurück zu stellen damit sie wecken soll
aber ja meistens komme ich glaube ich
die leute dann zurück an
und was war die reaktion reagiert man
mit aggression
von wegen hast du probleme warum hast du
mich an oder ist man eher freundlich
ich würde ja freundlich tendieren also
geht er ist so wie es ist mein langes
personen denen möchte man natürlich
nicht so lange die augen schaut findet
man es ein bisschen merkwürdig da würde
man aber auch nicht aggressiv reagieren
also ich nicht sondern wir halt eher so
ok ist halt so also wie reagieren leute
hier in deutschland wenn sie angestarrt
werden
viele sind schnell verunsichert wenn sie
angestellt angestarrt werden
ich weiß nicht genau woran das liegt
aber es ist sicherlich verständlich das
nochmal angeschaut wird und so ab einem
gewissen weil das irgendwie dann teil
keinen kann
ansprechen oder so was darauf folgt dann
für uns ist unsicher was man von der
jeweiligen person zu erwarten hat
erwarten soll
ich würde nicht zurück starren ich würde
weggucken und dem ganz schlimm fall mich
auch woanders hinstellen oder hinsetzen
also sie würden mich nicht konfrontieren
sie würden eher vermeiden ja ja ja
[Musik]
also die meisten können damit nicht
umgehen die gucken dann entweder
beschämt weg oder sie werden aggressiv
die wenigsten reagieren darauf und sagen
dann etwas sinnvolles oder zone also an
den vielen sachen die ich an deutschland
mag dies sei auch dass die interaktion
von den mönchen so freundlich ist im
zieljahr gibt es viele gibt wie gesagt
ich bin ein star und habe schon soviel
mal so oft es dass die leute gewunken
haben oder gelegen haben oft gibt es
auch
also es gibt 50 prozent so und 50
prozent so können sie sich erinnern an
eine situation wo sie sich unangenehm
berührt ja das kenne ich auch recht mal
in der u-bahn oder so also wenn er hat
schon nicht so groß ist und dass irgend
jemand ist der im unangenehm ist auch
angenehme leute dann freut man sich
vielleicht aber das habe ich auch schon
erlebt dass es mir unangenehm war ja
sicherlich war das für dich unangenehm
oder hast du verständnis für sein
ich glaube es kommt darauf an auf die
situation manchmal ist unangenehm aber
oft ist es einfach ganz normal man guckt
sich gegeneinander an
also wurde das du schon angespart und
würde es aber dabei ich hatte meinen
iranischen freund und dann sind wir
durch potsdam gelaufen und dann wurden
wir schon ziemlich doof angestellt doch
das habe ich schon gemerkt und wie bist
du damit fertig geworden ist es die war
das war das war das verlässlich für dich
oder hast du trotzdem ich gesagt ich
habe gesagt ich hab mich zu den leuten
[ __ ] euch gesagt ich habe sie weiter
auf angestarrt und hab dann gewartet bis
sie weggeschaut haben aber dadurch schon
wütend gemacht
denkst du dass es typisch deutsch dass
menschen andere menschen anstarren
anstatt ich werde mich ob man das
vielleicht gleich zu gleich setzen kann
mit jemandem mustern irgendwie wenn
manchmal anstalt oder dann kommt man da
meistens doch länger hin und dann musste
man irgendwann aber ob das ziemlich
deutsch ist nein nein ich glaube ich
nicht mehr ich nicht ich komme aus polen
und in polen wenn du jemanden an straßen
es ist gefährlich
so leute sind so unsicher dass sie sich
angegriffen fühlen und und mit mit
aggressionen der agieren ja also ich
kann das aus sondern häufiger in london
ist es auch so sonst niemanden einfach
an staaten so aber hier in berlin kann
es das kannst du das nicht bestätigen
in berlin ist ich bin selber ein starrer
weil ich auch ein kameramann bin und ich
habe so viele
ich habe so viele male erlebt dass die
leute sagt lächeln und winken und ich
liebe das ist für mich natürlich sah wie
lieb ist es definitiv das ist
ich kann das was du was du meinst es
kommt aber glaube ich was ich alles viel
darauf an was man was man ausstrahlt und
die man den man auch leute wirkt und
wenn man sage ich mal eine gewisse
sympathie ausstrahlt oder freundlich
wirkt dann haben die wenigsten leute
angst oder finden sich schon sicher ich
glaube es kommt immer auf die situation
darauf an aber ich grundsätzlich
versuche es eigentlich zu vermeiden weil
ich glaube dass ist für andere menschen
unangenehm reicht von mir ausgehe
es gibt sicherlich ecken wo das nicht so
gelassen ist aber ich sag mal in berlin
da sind wir so multikulti wir haben so
viele nationen hier
und das interessiert eigentlich glaube
ich auch gar keinen weil du kannst hier
in berlin sein wer du willst du kannst
auch umlauf wie du willst und machen was
du willst und die wenigsten stören sich
daran das gehört einfach zu berlin dazu
das ist die lebensphilosophie sagt ich
mache jetzt wollen wir von euch wissen
habt ihr schon mal diese erfahrung
gemacht wurde ihr in deutschland
angestellt wie geht ihr damit um und
besonders interessant wie ist das in
euren ländern start man da oder ist das
einfach absolut unhöflich oder absolut
gefährlich sowie in polen veganisch sagt
oder in england auch hier hast du gerade
erst auf der straße hier gelernt nun das
wusste ich schon immer ich wurde selber
fast verprügelt schon einen engländer
nur weil ich zufällig angeguckt habe und
dann richtete er sich noch aufspürt
ich dachte so recht zurecht ja man kann
auch übertreiben will
wir wollen gerne eure meinung wissen
schreibt sie unten und ihr wollt
bestimmt auch weiter üben mit dem
vokabular zur heutigen episode und mit
den ausdrücken
die bekommt ihr nämlich als mitglied von
the german bei patchen da könnt ihr
interaktive übungen machen und mit den
vokabeln lernen und als mitglied da
könnt ihr um ein mitglied zu werden
könnt ihr einfach hier oder hier klicken
und wir begrüßen euch viel spaß dabei
bis bald ciao ciao
[Musik]